so we're here once again
uh on the texas border
dealing with the ongoing failure of the
bite administration to do its
fundamental job and that is to secure
our border
we could never forget that it was just a
year and a half ago that we had some of
the lowest border crossings in the past
few decades and that's because we had a
president who was very aggressively
enforcing the remaining mexico policy in
the title 42 policy and enforcing the
immigration laws passed by the united
states congress
now however we have a president who is
using lax enforcement of title 42 of the
remaining
remaining mexican policy as well as
lacks enforcement of the border laws and
as a result we have a record high number
of people who are coming across the
border
about a month ago
my team working along with the texas
department of public safety and the
texas national guard
we begin preparing
for something that we shouldn't have to
prepare for
we begin preparing for this uh oncoming
caravan or caravans that are headed our
way we shouldn't have to do it because
again it's the bite administration's job
to be doing this but because they're not
doing it we've been working
for about a month now to be prepared for
these care bans that are coming our way
before coming out here i had a briefing
with the national guard as well as with
the texas department of public safety uh
and here's the latest news they shared
with me
about the status of the caravans
they say that
some evidence makes it seem as though
the caravans are disbanding to some
extent
part of it is maybe because of a lack of
resources part of it may be because the
weather part of it may be because of
other conditions
that said
even if the caravans are breaking up
it doesn't mean that the people who were
part of the caravans are not going to be
trying to make it to the united states
of america it's just that they may be
making here in ones or twos as opposed
to large caravans
there are some other reasons why
the the caravans are breaking up
and that is
the consequence of the agreements that i
reached with the governors of mexico
where they are doing their part to help
secure the border from the mexico side
of the border this includes state police
activity on the mexico side upholding
their end of the bargain to slow
migration
includes internal checkpoints on their
side in mexico helping to slow migrant
movement toward the border
as well as what we call mirrored
activity what that means is when
state law enforcement on the texas side
are under attacking undertaking
military and police movements
on the mexico side they are mirroring
that operation
one thing that does is it slows or
eliminates the cartel activity in that
particular region whenever we slow or
deter cartel activity that will slow and
border crossings in that particular area
the national guard and dps are working
also on an intensified strategy
and that is to
block
as many low water crossings as possible
one of the easiest ways for
illegal immigrants to cross into the
united states is through these low water
crossings and so we're using multiple
strategies to try to block those low
water crossings
and we're also working on let's say the
national guard and dps are working on
mass migration rehearsals
what that means is they are prepared to
implement certain strategies but also
have the flexibility to move those
strategies to the locations where the
mass migration may occur uh it may be
that we
are fully prepared at this particular
bridge to block migration in this
particular area and the cartels learn
about that and they may try to move the
activity to a different region what that
means is that we need to have the
flexibility to move our resources to
another region to make sure that we can
block the crossings in that particular
region
also
dps
as well as the national guard
continue to deploy all the resources
they possibly can
to help secure this region of texas
there are three particular regions of
the state of texas that we're most
focused on right now
one is where we are right now which is
hidalgo county
maverick county and alberta county
maverick county is where eagle pass is
in alberta county
is where del rio is
let's see
for the
that is uh the main thing i wanted to
share with you i'm going to have
both
leaders from the national guard and the
texas department of public safety
share with you more details
first national guard major general
burkett
yeah good afternoon so as the governor
alluded um we've got uh a task force
maneuver task force here in what we call
task force east it's one of five
maneuver task forces that we have uh
from
from our southern sector all the way up
past um del rio uh and and just further
north uh to van horn and beyond but
but what we practice uh on a weekly
basis is we rehearse the mass migration
response events and there's a
combination of of hasty blocking
positions where we can move mass amounts
of troops and vehicles uh in conjunction
with with dps and law enforcement agents
to have a very heavy presence where we
think it's needed to deter or to turn
back a migration event
we also
practice those routinely without the law
enforcement so that we can demonstrate
that we have the capability of massive
soldiers and moving and establishing
blocking positions in the middle of the
night we can do it in the heat of the
day we can do it early in the morning we
conduct boat operations uh both here in
an eagle pass and a del rio as well
provide that deterrence and that early
detection and warning along the river
we've got a task force engineers in
addition to our maneuver elements
that are responsible for establishing
additional barriers where we have the
land use agreements we've got nearly uh
40 miles of standard fencing that's been
erected to date and another 18 miles of
concertina wire to service that barrier
and that deterrence
thank you very much and it's my
understanding
one thing that the national guard
achieves are what are called turnbacks
and you all have documented about 20 000
turnbacks is that correct yes sir yes
sir absolutely all right thank you
and now from the texas department of
public safety lieutenant colonel freeman
martin thank you governor
uh 2021 was
a record-breaking year in many ways and
none of them good
we saw 1.3 million apprehensions here in
texas the highest error
i believe the next heist was in 1986
with 723 thousand so almost doubled in
2021 uh fentanyl we had a 1268
increase in fentanyl seizures these are
state seizures not federal government
in texas in 2021 and if you compare
january to may of 2021 to january of may
of 2022 we have an additional 58
increase
so
obviously there's a lot of threats that
we face here in the state of texas the
unsecured border with mexico is at the
top of the list
uh what we're doing right here in the
dogwood county with with an operation
when i say we i mean operation lone star
that's all of the state agencies that
are involved in this operation with
parks and wildlife tmd is very heavy uh
dps and a lot of state agencies uh
tremendous amount of success in shutting
down the the highest traffic areas in
the entire
southern border is in hindu county the
rio grande valley and it has always been
securing the zones that they have
secured in in right here in this county
into dogwood county and we see those
numbers drop and we deter caravans we
deter
work with our mexican counterparts uh
but but the one thing that has a had a
significant
difference in this operation is these
government these agreements that
governor abbott signed with our mexican
counterparts we have never had the
cooperation and collaboration that we
have today with our state counterparts
across the border they're working with
their mirroring
our operations along the border they
help us as we see a surge in one area
they they
as i said these numbers are high we
would rather the numbers be zero if we
can deter if we can prevent that that's
what success looks like and working with
our our counterparts on the other side
of the river we're for the first time
seeing the cooperation and collaboration
like we've never seen before so thank
you for that governor and uh that's all
i had thank you
i want to go back and emphasize the
point that he just made
and it's the
seizure of fentanyl
so operation lone star and the texas
department of public safety over the
past year
have seized almost
enough fentanyl to kill every man woman
and child in the entire united states of
america the reason why that must be
underscored is that as fentanyl they got
past border patrol
if it were not for operation lone star
the texas department of public safety
and texas law enforcement that would be
fentanyl on the streets in the united
states killing americans across our
country and it just goes to show the way
that the vitamin administration and
their approach to not securing the
border uh is exposing to america's
across the entire country to deadly
fentanyl with that we'll be having to
take a few questions
governor uh the caravans have been
dismantled but they the migrants are
still moving forward um getting ready to
receive many thousands more the shelters
are going to be also packed again
how are we going to respond so
a point that you made is uh the
information that we are getting is that
to a large extent the large caravans are
being disbanded however that does not
mean uh that the people who were part of
those caravans will not continue to try
to make their way to the border
our response is the same and that is we
will be utilizing every tool and
strategy that we can uh to make sure
that ill illegal immigration will not be
able to take place vhs is now thinking
about moving migrants to los angeles
albuquerque houston and dallas something
that
you at one point were doing as well well
what dhs needs to do
is their job their job is to enforce the
laws passed by the united states
congress that would mean to stop the
illegal immigration from occurring in
the first place it would mean not tying
the hands of ice not tying the hands of
the border patrol officers but rather
unleashing them to do their job
governor uh new cbp numbers show that uh
there have been 50 people on the terror
watch list arrested here at the southern
border just this fiscal year alone
that's more than the last five years
combined your reaction to that that's
one of the most reprehensible things the
administration is doing so you talked
about 50 people on the terrorist watch
list who've been apprehended what you
did not mention is all of those on the
terrorist watch list who got away if
you're on the terror watch list you will
be spending more money to the cartels to
try to evade being caught so what that
means is there's a high probability that
there are a lot of people on the tarot
watch list who've been
who've come into the united states
this is the president's job
national security and our national
security is at risk because of all these
terrorists who are on the watch list who
may have come across the border the
president of the united states is
failing in his most fundamental duty and
that is to keep our nation safe
your initiative to send
migrants by bus to washington we see a
new report that shows that over 1.6
million spend on this initiative where's
the money coming from how much more
you're going to spend and how does that
work
so first i will tell you this
i wish we weren't sending anybody
anywhere and the only reason why we're
having to put people on buses and send
them to washington dc is because the
body administration is not only not
doing their job but the body
administration is
apprehending people who cross the border
illegally and then dumping them in
cities that have no capability of
handling them whatsoever and so cities
and small towns along the real real
ground and along the border need our
help to move those migrants elsewhere
and so we're doing our part to try to
help our local communities
and uh the the we are we're hoping that
meaningful parts of the funding will
continue to come from donations people
can help out by going to an online site
borderbuss.texas.gov
to contribute but the bottom line is
this we will continue to alleviating the
costs
that local governments would otherwise
have to be responsible for had it not
been for the body administration's open
border policies
still willing to hire some border patrol
agents like in your 100
and listen again it's despicable uh that
these border patrol agents that were on
those horses who were using reins to
control those horses have been
completely exonerated by all law
enforcement agencies and yet the blind
administration uh it still seems intent
on punishing those border
patrol officers
as governor i'd be more than happy i'd
be honored to have those border patrol
officers be a part of the texas team to
secure the border two more questions
president biden has never been to the
border would you invite him
we have demanded
that joe biden come to the border and
not for a a candy coated tour he needs
to see the struggles of what people in
del rio are dealing with he needs to see
the ranches that have been ripped apart
by the illegal immigration that he has
allowed he needs to talk to the people
whose lives have been completely
disruptive he needs to talk to angel
moms who have lost a child because of an
illegal immigrant in the united states
of america he needs to see firsthand the
chaos that he has caused last question
we have seen of course like uh on the
news videos and everything what's
happening here not only here in the
valley but all in the border do you
think he's just not paying attention
you're just pretending not to see what
is actually happening here at the border
remember that joe biden campaigned on
the promise of open border policies the
chaos that you were talking about that
we're seeing on our border is chaos that
joe biden promised when he campaigned
for president of the united states and
the american people are fed up with it
the people in the real grand valley the
people who live in border communities
many of whom may have supported biden as
president
now want to reject him as president
because they cannot stand what his open
border policies are doing to their state
and to their country great thank you
guys
thank you all
thank you
thank you again for everything you do
everything you do every single day
appreciate it keep it up what do you
think
oh
foreign